Wall Street Zentralbanken und
Privatinvestoren haben eines gemeinsam
sie haben ein wachsendes Interesse an
kryptowährungen laut coinshares
erreichten die Investitionen in
kryptofonds und Produkte im ersten
Quartal dieses Jahres einen Rekordwert
von 4,5 Milliarden Dollar das Vermögen
in den USA beträgt 140 Billionen Dollar
weltweit sogar 400 ein halbes% des
globalen Vermögens ist in
kryptowährungen angelegt bis zum Ende
des Jahres werden wir wohl ein% erreicht
haben Bitcoin bekommt die meiste
Aufmerksamkeit unter seinen
kryptokollegen doch Kritiker haben
Bedenken in Hinsicht der Struktur und
ihrer Volatilität im Wesentlichen haben
wir nur ein weiteres Tauschmittel
erschaffen das irgendwo in einem
Computer existiert es hat keinen echten
Wert kein Nutzen und liefert keine
brauchbaren Dienste es ist eine Blase es
ist die zugrunde liegende Technologie
einer blockchain die das Interesse der
Investoren weckt laut CB insights haben
Startups die sich auf blockchain
konzentrieren allein im ersten Quartal
dieses Jahres rund 2,5 Milliarden Dollar
eingesammelt das ist mehr als im
gesamten Jahr 2020 in Wirklichkeit sehen
wir hier den Aufbau einer Infrastruktur
auf der tatsächlich Transaktionen
durchgeführt werden können auch die
Zentralbanken spüren den Druck eigene
digitalwährungen zu schaffen eine
kürzlich durchgeführte Umfrage der
Banken ergab dass 86% der Zentralbanken
der Zeit daran arbeiten 2017 waren es
noch
65% frage ich mich ob Bitcoin nicht
teilweise als eine Art finanzwaffe
Chinas gegen die USA angesehen werden
sollte es bedroht nicht nur das Fiat
Geld es bedroht vor allem den
US-Dollar doch wie denkt Europa über
kryptowährungen die Digitalisierung ist
mittlerweile in allen Bereichen unseres
Lebens spürbar und hat bereits die Art
und Weise wie wir bezahlen verändert ein
digitaler Euro wäre ein Symbol für den
Fortschritt in Europa und die
europäische Integration er würde als
Geld in elektronischer Form vom
Eurosystem der EZB und den nationalen
Zentralbanken des Euroraums ausgegeben
und könnte gleichermaßen von
Privatpersonen und Unternehmen verwendet
werden das Bargeld würde durch ihn nicht
ersetzt sondern
ergänzt
wer weiß wie die Zukunft der Banken
aussehen wird einer der es vielleicht
wissen könnte ist Ravi mannon er war bis
2011 Staatssekretär im Ministerium für
Handel und Industrie und leitet nun die
Zentralbank eines Landes das als eines
der intelligentesten und
fortschrittlichsten Finanzzentren der
Welt Gil
Singapur Ravi Mennen vielen Dank dass
Sie sich heute Zeit genommen haben Ravi
vor nicht allzu langer Zeit hielten sich
die Zentralbanken von digitalen
Währungen komplett fern aber die Lage
hat sich verändert ich meine wir haben
Länder wie Schweden die Bahamas und
China die darüber reden möglicherweise
Ihre eigene digitale Währung in Umlauf
zu bringen wie sollten Zentralbanken in
Sachen digitale Währung in Zukunft
involviert
sein ja ich denke wir sollten hier
unbedingt involviert sein das heißt wir
müssen mit der Technologie Schritt
halten auch wenn wir dabei am Anfang
viel Leergeld bezahlen durch dasuben
Projekt Konten wir wertvolle Erfahrung
als wir unsere digitale Währung den
Singapur Dollar auf einer blockchain in
Umlauf gebracht haben ich denke es ist
wichtig sich mit dieser Technologie
auseinanderzusetzen und sich nicht davor
zu
verstecken Jasper uben war ein
Gemeinschaftsprojekt des kanadischen
blockchain Netzwerks corda und des
quorumnetzwerks in Singapur aus einer
Kooperation der monetary authority of
Singapur und der kanadischen Zentralbank
wurde 2016 untersucht ob es einfachere
und effizientere Zahlungs und Abwicklung
Systeme durch die Ausgabe digitaler
Token mit Hilfe der Zentralbanken geben
kann in der ersten Phase wurde ein
digitales Token eququivalent des
Singapur Dollars ausgegeben dieser
beruhte auf einer proof of conzcept
basierenden ethereum blockchain den als
catcoin bezeichneten kanadischen
digitalen Dollar entwickelte man um zu
verstehen wie blockchains in realen
zahlungsabwicklungsszenarien genutzt
werden können Phase 2 stand für die
Einführung von Software Prototypen für
interbankenzahlungen hauptsächlich war
Microsoft am mit beauftragt diese
Prototypen in ihrer Azure blockchain
bereitzustellen in der letzten Phase
wurden Möglichkeiten zuur Integration
der Plattform und der digitalen Assets
unter Wahrung der Privatsphäre der
Marktteilnehmer untersucht Jasper uben
war ein voller Erfolg so konnten die
Bank of Canada und die monetary
authority of Singapore versuchsweise ein
schnelleres und kostengünstigeres
grenzüberschreitendes Zahlungssystem
entwickeln wir müssen unsere Perspektive
etwas ändern und uns Fragen zu welchem
Zweck was soll eine digitale Währung
leisten müssen wir unterscheiden
zwischen einer grenzüberschreitenden
Handelswährung und einer
einzelhandelswährung für Konsumenten bei
einer digitalen Handelswährung würde es
sich um genau das Handeln was wir als
blockchain kennen es kommt hier nicht
auf jeden einzelnen digitalen Token an
aber in Summe werden mit ihrer Hilfe die
eigentlichen Transaktionen durchgeführt
nach diesem System würde zumindest
Singapur eine digitale Währung in Umlauf
bringen Kanada würde gerne eine digitale
Währung herausgeben um
grenzüberschreitenden Zahl ehr zu
vereinfachen aber sie kommen nicht so
einfach aus ihrem Bankensystem heraus
weil die Leute immer noch an
traditioneller F Währung festhalten wenn
also ihr Ansatz nur grenzüberschreitende
Zahlungen sind brauchen sie keine
digitale einzelhandelswährung
unterschiedliche Währungen spielen also
in diesem Szenario keine Rolle das heißt
Zentralbanken geben digitale Währungen
direkt an die Öffentlichkeit raus und
wir sehen im Moment keinen Bedarf für
eine separate einzelhandelswährung ein
digitaler Euro würde also die Effizienz
eines modernen Zahlungsmittels bieten
und wäre gleichzeitig sicheres
Zentralbankgeld es würde sich dort
anbieten wo Menschen ungern mit Bargeld
bezahlen der Schutz der Privatsphäre
sollte beim Euro einen hohen Stellenwert
haben so kann er dazu beitragen das
Vertrauen in den heutigen
Zahlungsverkehr aufrecht zu erhalten er
könnte den Übergang der europäischen
Wirtschaft in die Digitalisierung
unterstützen und Innovationen im
massenzahlungsverkehr aktiv fördern
derzeit prüfen die EZB und die
nationalen Zentralbanken des
welche Vorteile und Risiken ein
digitaler Euro hätte denn der Anstieg
von Vermögenswerten wie bitcoin ist
größer als die damalige südseeblase oder
die niederländische
[Musik]
tulpenblase nun wissen Sie unser Ansatz
ist diese Art von Vermögenswerten
erstmal genau zu prüfen für uns ist
Bitcoin keine Währung es ist für uns
klar eine Wertanlage es ist ein
Vermögenswert dem nur sehr wenig
zugrunde liegt was zu einer Menge
Volatilität führt sie wenn man hier
versucht herauszufinden was der
wirkliche Wert des Assets ist in das man
investiert hat stößt man schnell auf
Schwierigkeiten und das ist genau der
Punkt dass Renditen dieser Art von
kryptowertanlagen nicht mit der Rendite
anderer Anlagen vergleichbar sind
deshalb müssen Anleger die in
kryptovermögenswerte investiert haben
ihr Portfolio so gut es geht
streuen meiner Meinung nach macht es
nicht viel Sinn hier zu investieren da
man das Problem der starken Volatilität
hat vor ein paar Monaten hatten wir noch
die Situation dass die Preise durch die
Decke schossen und nun sehen sie ja wo
wir stehen das macht das alles sehr
schwierig wenn Sie also Schwierigkeiten
haben herauszufinden was die eigentliche
Basis oder Grundlage ihrer Investition
ist dann denke ich haben sie keine
wirkliche Investition getätigt sondern
spekuliert auch wenn es sich anders
anfühlt diese starken Preisschwankungen
zeigen dass es nur wenig Vertrauen z.B
in stablecoins
gibt eine Währung sollte mit keine
Anlage für Spekulationen sein oder in
dieser Richtung Anreize schaffen sondern
ein stabiles Element unserer Geldpolitik
darstellen würde also ein digitaler Euro
nicht zu den kryptoassets zählen
kryptoassets unterscheiden sich
grundlegend von Zentralbankgeld ihre
Preise unterliegen häufig großen
Schwankungen sodass sie nur schwer als
konstantes Zahlungsmittel zu verwenden
sind zudem steht hinter ihnen meist
keine vertrauenswürdige
Institution der Zahlungsverkehr befindet
sich im und die Zentralbanken spielen
dabei eine wichtige Rolle Grundlage des
europäischen Zahlungsverkehrs muss ein
wettbewerbsfähiger und innovativer
zahlungsmarkt sein der die Bedürfnisse
der VerbraucherInnen erfüllt und die
Souveränität Europas wart Fachleute der
EZB und der nationalen Zentralbanken des
Euroraums haben eine Reihe grundlegender
Anforderungen für einen digitalen Euro
festgelegt beispielsweise muss er leicht
zugänglich robust sicher und effizient
sein es gibt also eine Menge Punkte die
bei der ein fhrung einer digitalen
Währung zu beachten sind meint auch der
ehemalige CFO von Goldman Sax Martin
Chavez ich kann leider noch nicht sagen
welche Form genau die digitalwährung
einer Zentralbank annehmen wird es ist
nicht mal zu 100% klar ob dieser auf
einer blockchain existieren muss oder
nicht sie muss auf jeden Fall weit
verbreitet sein die Privatsphäre muss
geschützt sein und es sollte eine
gewisse Fehlertoleranz geben wir sehen
hier auf diesem Gebiet geopolitische
Überlagerungen und dass einige Staaten
wie z.B China dieses Thema sehr
aggressiv angehen und eine digitale
Währung einführen ich weiß zwar nicht
wie die Gespräche hinter verschlossenen
Türen aussehen aber natürlich möchte man
den internationalen Handel gerne in
dieser Währung abwickeln als bisher in
Dollar auf der anderen Seite ist man
noch sehr skeptisch da vielleicht
Überwachung eine große Rolle spielt oder
sogar seine Souveränität an die Nutzung
der digitalen Währung geknüpft ist der
Schutz der Privatsphäre die Bekämpfung
von Geldwäsche und die Transparenz für
Kunden das ist alles sehr sehr schwierig
in wicht zu bringen aber ich möchte auf
etwas anderes zurückkommen dass ich vor
10 Jahren den früheren Bitcoin CEOs
profizzeit habe und ich denke es hängt
damit zusammen damals meinte ich dass
ich sehr zuversichtlich bin dass die Fed
die Digitalisierung des US-Dollars
fortsetzen wird und eines Tages wird er
ein digitales asset sein quasi eine
kryptowährung es hieß das würde nie
passieren aber ich sagte sag niemals nie
und nun bin ich sicher dass es in naher
Zukunft passieren wird es gibt
Unterschiede in der Denkweise von Leuten
an Ost und westkü
die Art und Weise wie in Silicon Valley
an Sachen herangegangen wird
unterscheidet sich doch sehr von der in
New York oder DC aber irgendwann wird es
auch hier ein Umdenken
geben wir können die Vorboten bereits
sehen wer die Beratungen des Kongresses
in den Tiefen der Pandemie genau
verfolgt hat wurde vielleicht an die
früheren konjunkturgesetze der Federal
Reserve Bank erinnert einen digitalen
US-Dollar zu schaffen und diesen an die
Amerikaner zu verteilen ich weiß noch
wie ich dachte das ist wirklich eine
gute Idee
aber es ist und bleibt ein wirklich
unglaublich riesiges Projekt es gibt
sowohl für den groß als auch für den
Einzelhandel die Möglichkeit das
Zahlungssystem weiter zu modernisieren
und sie werden mit der Digitalisierung
noch lange zu kämpfen haben bis Ihr
Bankkonto ein komplett digitales
Konstrukt sein
wird die Frage ist wollen wir dass es
kontobasiert ist soll es genauso
funktionieren wie unsere
papierdollarscheine nur eben als
digitaler Token das sind alles Themen
die im Moment sehr aktiv diskutiert
werden ich erinnere mich noch als der
argentinische Peso an den Dollar
gekoppelt war das war großartig man
konnte Pesos am Geldautomaten bekommen
und das lag daran dass die
währungsbehörde beide Währungen Dollars
und Pesos gleichermaßen verfügbar machte
und das ist jetzt die Herausforderung
bei den
stablecoins ich denke es ist eine
absolute Notwendigkeit jetzt einen
digitalen Dollar in Umlauf zu bringen
Amerika und die
sind hier in
Zugzwang und nicht nur wieder so eine
Übergangslösung nein ich denke es ist
unvermeidlich dass wir jetzt Nägel mit
Köpfen machen denn wenn wir etwas aus
der Politikwissenschaft kennen ist es
Souveränität einzuhalten ein souveräner
Staat kann seine Steuern nur in der
Währung verlangen die er auch
ausgibt und das ist ja auch gerade das
was die Zirkularität dieser Währung noch
unterbindet was wäre wenn der gesamte
internationale Handel in ich bezahlt und
alles slos gegen den digitalen han
getauscht werden könnte würden ihn die
Leute dann tatsächlich verwenden
vielleicht würde ich ein Konto für Hanan
eröffnen okay man müsste mich erst
einmal davon überzeugen dass meine
Privatsphäre geschützt wird und nicht
einfach nur sagen dass es so ist es
müsste mathematisch kryptographisch
garantiert sein dass meine Privatsphäre
gewahrt wird und ich bin mir vollkommen
sicher dass solche Gespräche gerade
stattfinden Martin chz spricht hier
einen wichtigen Punkt an wie sieht es
aus mit der Akzeptanz eines digitalen
Euros es wurden Bedenken geäußert dass
Zentralbanken durch die Einführung einer
eigenen digitalen Währung in den Besitz
sensibler Informationen über die
NutzerInnen gelangen könnten bei privat
emittierten zahlungsinstrumenten wie z.B
stablecoins ist das Risiko in den Besitz
sensibler Informationen zu gelangen sehr
groß die meisten NutzerInnen und
InvestorInnen sind auch besorgt dass neu
entstehende private Zahlungslösungen
insbesondere wenn sie unreguliert sind
Risiken mit sich bringen können im Falle
eines digitalen Euros könnten solche
Risiken durch die Beteiligung der
Zentralbank gemildert werden eine
globale Meinungsumfrage zum öffentlichen
Vertrauen in monetäre Institutionen
zahlungsmerkmale und digitale Währungen
zeigt die Bedeutung des Vertrauens in
die zugrunde liegenden Systeme während
rund 79% aller Zahlungen im Euroraum
immer noch bargeldtransaktionen sind
Sankt der Anteil dieser Transaktionen
zwischen 2017 und 19 allein in den
Niederlanden von 41 auf
32%. gerade junge Europäerinnen machen
laut jüngsten EZB Umfragen ausgiebig
Gebrauch von Bargeld bevorzugen aber
elektronische Zahlungen und erwarten von
der entsprechenden Infrastruktur dass
sie Sicherheit und Schnelligkeit
garantiert auch die covid-19 Krise hat
zu einer Verschiebung der
Zahlungsgewohnheiten hin zu kontaktlosen
Zahlungen und E-Commerce geführt diese
Verlagerung hin zu kontaktlosen
Zahlungen fand statt obwohl Banknoten im
Vergleich zu anderen Arten von
Oberflächen mit denen Menschen im
täglichen Leben in Kontakt kommen kein
besonders großes Risiko einer
coronavirusinfektion darstellen in der
Pandemie beschleunigte sich das
Innovationstempo und die BürgerInnen
zeigen eine zunehmende Vorliebe für
digitale Zahlungen vor diesem
Hintergrund hat der ezbrat im Januar
2020 eine hochrangige Taskforce
eingerichtet um die Arbeit an digitalen
zentralbankwährungen im Euroraum
voranzutreiben würde ein digitaler Euro
also von der EZB zentral verwaltet
werden Brian Brooks war lang Zeit Teil
des Bankensystems und meint
Dezentralität ist der Schlüssel in
meinem letzten Job für die Regierung und
Leitung des Bankensystems haben wir
versucht klar zuum machen dass wir weder
Fanatiker noch Feinde von
kryptowährungen sind aber wir glauben
dass die Märkte Richtlinien und Klarheit
brauchen ich sage nicht dass mehr oder
weniger Kontrolle eine gute Sache ist
aber eine Reihe von Regeln zu haben wäre
für mich gut vorstellbar stellen sich
nur mal vor Straßen ohne Tempolimit
niemand weiß ob man schnell oder langsam
fahren soll das wäre fahrlässig wir
haben Tempolimits an die sich jeder
halten kann und so etwas brauchen wir
auch bei kryptowährungen ich denke die
Anziehungskraft von Krypto liegt eher in
der Dezentralisierung und weniger in der
fehlenden Regulierung denn hier liegt
die wahre Herausforderung worum es hier
wirklich geht ist der Aufbau eines
Finanzsystems abseits der
Zentralisierung Leute die denken wir
versuchen geheimes magisches
internetgeld zu erschaffen das nicht
überwacht werden kann sind
wahrscheinlich in der falschen Branche
es geht um ein dezentrales Finanzsystem
das nicht von bänern kontrolliert wird
das wird der große Vorteil der
kryptowährungen sein und was ist mit der
Stabilität zumindest wenn man sich
andere Märkte anschaut Stabilität ist
oft mit Zentralisierung verbunden oder
war zumindest eine Folge davon
schließlich hatten die USA eine
dezentralisierte Wirtschaft bis man sich
entschied eine Fett zu gründen um eine
Art von Stabilität zu erzeugen doch wenn
wir hier ein System von Regeln wie z.B
Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen wollen
gleicht das nicht schon fast einer
Zentralisierung wir haben die Fed im 19
Jahrhundert nicht gegründet weil die
Dezentralisierung schlecht war sondern
weil wir keine technologische
Möglichkeit hatten den Menschen zu
erlauben direkt miteinander zu handeln
und so musste jemand Dollar in Umlauf
bringen die überall akzeptiert werden
konnten aber jetzt haben wir eine
Technologie die das für uns tut sehen
Sie in der Vergangenheit war die Post
die einzige Möglichkeit um Informationen
auszutauschen es gab für jemanden in New
York keine Möglichkeit Nachrichten nach
San Francisco zu übermitteln jetzt haben
wir E-Mail und brauchen die Post nicht
mehr so verdrängen Technologien manchmal
ganze Institutionen die wir zuvor
aufgebaut haben wenn wir also weiterhin
nach Stabilität suchen würde ich sagen
ist diese sehr brüchig es war zwar
stabil aber es wurde alles streng
reguliert und kontrolliert es war auch
unglaublich teuer und hat letztendlich
nicht gut funktioniert es war lediglich
das Beste was wir hatten nun haben wir
etwas besseres die EZB ist die Hüterin
des Euros ob es sich um Banknoten und
Münzen oder um einen Euro in digitaler
Form handelt spielt dabei keine Rolle
unsere Aufgabe ist es den Wert unserer
gemeinsamen Währung zu erhalten
unabhängig von seiner Form soll ein
Digital Euro letztendlich von der
zuständigen Zentralbank geschützt und
reguliert werden ein wesentlicher Teil
der Aufgabe des Eurosystems besteht
darin die BürgerInnen mit risikolosem
Geld für ihre Zahlungen zu versorgen
Beld ist zwar immer noch das
vorherrschende Zahlungsmittel doch neue
Technologien und die zunehmende
Nachfrage der VerbraucherInnen nach
Unmittelbarkeit verändern die Art und
Weise wie die europäischen Bürgerinnen
bezahlen dies zeigt sich in der rasanten
Zunahme elektronischer
Zahlungen gib guten Grund dafür dass der
Umlauf durch das Bankensystem reguliert
wird weil Banken nämlich aus der
monetären Basis ihrer Kreditvergaben
sozusagen dem kreditschöpfungsprozess
Geld erschaffen wenn die Zentralbanken
nun direkt digitale Währungen an die
Allgemeinheit ausgeben würden was würden
dann die Zentralbanken mit diesem
digitalen Geld machen das Geld der
Zentralbanken ist nicht darauf
ausgerichtet Leuten den Kreditrahmen zu
vergrößern das ist die Aufgabe der
Banken wir müssen also darüber
nachdenken wie in der Praxis
funktionieren soll und man muss auch
fragen warum überhaupt warum sollen die
Zentralbanken die digitalen Währungen
ausgeben weil abgesehen von den
grenzüberschreitenden Zahlungen für den
Einzelhandel ich denke es ist viel mehr
eine geldpolitische Frage als eine rein
politische die Menschen haben das Gefühl
an digitales äquivalent zu Bargeld zu
brauchen das alle Eigenschaften von
Bargeld
hat undkommen Akzeptanz um nur die
beiden wichtigsten zu nennen wenn ich
eine Banküberweisung auf Ihr Konto mache
ist das allenfalls vertraulich aber wenn
die Behörden den Verdacht haben dass
etwas nicht stimmt können Sie die
Transaktion aufheben und untersuchen so
verfolgen wir ja Geldwäsche oder
Steuerhinterziehung und können diese
aufdecken denn es gibt immer eine
digitale Spur die
transaktionsaufzeichnung wenn wir nun
komplett auf einen digitalen
Zahlungsverkehr umsteigen verlieren die
Leute genau diese absolute des Bargelds
wenn ich ihnen einen Koffer voller
Bargeld gebe gibt es keine Möglichkeit
das zurückzu
verfolgen warum braucht es dann
überhaupt Zentralbank Geld bzw einen
digitalen Euro für Haushalte und Firmen
in einer zunehmend verzahnten und vor
allem digitalisierten Welt hingt der
Zahlungsverkehr dem Tempo der Wirtschaft
oft noch
hinterher Regulierungen
sorgfalltspflichten und unterschiedliche
itsysteme zwischen Banken und
Währungsräumen können gerade bei
Auslandsüberweisungen noch immer Tage
dauern das ist nicht nur ineffizient
sondern erzeugt auch zusätzliche Kosten
Bitcoin oder Facebooks Währung dim
beabsichtigen genau dieses Problem zu
beheben jedoch nicht ganz ohne Risiken
für NutzerInnen dafür die Stabilität der
Währung schließlich keiner garantiert
wie die hohen Preisschwankungen von
Bitcoin deutlich machten ein digitaler
Euro als Wertanlage der in unbegrenztem
Umfang verfügbar ist wäre daher auch
nicht zweckdienlich Vorteile würden
damit nur indirekt entstehen wenn
Transaktionen beispielsweise beim
Onlinekauf schneller abgewickelt würden
und Firmen direkter und transparenter
Überblick über Kontostände und
Transaktionen hätten die immer wieder
geäußerte Angst die EZB wolle damit den
Leuten das Bargeld wegnehmen ist daher
haltlos die von der EZB initiierte
digitale Revolution wäre also für
Anlegerinnen und InvestorInnen anfangs
nicht
[Musik]
spürbar das bringt uns zu Libra wir
hatten VISA Mastercard die
zurückzogen die G7 staten mnten zur
Vorsicht wie stehen Sie dazu da ja
Facebook sagt dass die
Regulierungsbehörden die Regulierung
hinauszögern und das gleichbedeutend
damit ist Innovation zu deckeln bzw zu
bremsen wir begrüßen die Innovation ich
denke der Ansatz von facebook hat eine
enorme Menge an neuen Ideen und eine
neue Art zu denken hervorgebracht was
meiner Meinung nach essenell für die
und wie sie eben gesagt haben hat das
Interesse der Zentralbanken an digitalen
Währungen durch das Projekt von Facebook
anen großen Schub
bekommen die Kernaussage von Facebook
ist dass es grenzüberschreitende
Zahlungen billiger schneller und besser
machen will und es will die finanzielle
Inklusion verbessern weil es viel
einfacher ist ein Facebook Konto zu
haben als ein
Bankkonto auf den ersten Blick sind das
hochgesteckte
Ziele Zentralbanken und die
bankengemeinschaft müssen hier an
Antworten für Firmen wie Facebook
arbeiten denn so etwas brauchen
wir das wurde in gewisser Hinsicht etwas
verschlafen und wenn überhaupt nicht gut
umgesetzt ich will damit nicht sagen
dass Facebooks anatz schlecht ist aber
er zeigt hier eine echte Lücke auf und
ich verstehe die Idee
dahinter eine weitere Nuance in der
ganzen Problematik der Zentralbank und
der digitalen Währung ist die Frage geht
hier nur um Zahlungen geht es hier nur
um Anonymität ich denke der ganze
Widerstand hat auch mit der Dominanz des
US-Dollars zu tun ob das eine gesunde
Sache für die globale Finanzstabilität
ist denn wenn zwei Länder miteinander
Handel treiben oder zwei Menschen
Transaktionen durchführen wird immer
auch ein Teil des Dollars umgerechnet
unsere Wechselkurse die bilateralen
Wechselkurse beziehen sich alle auf den
US-Dollar n eine oder schlechte Sache
nun das System hat bis jetzt ziemlich
gut funktioniert doch für die Zukunft
ist es nicht unvernünftig zu fragen ob
das noch der beste Weg ist hier
weiterzukommen oder ob wir nicht ein
stabileres System von globalen
Reservewährungen finden sollten es soll
sich ja nicht wieder alles um die
Vereinigten Staaten
drehen aber es scheint dies wäre die
Denkweise der Regulatoren und
Zentralbanken wir haben hier eine starke
Konzentration auf den US-Dollar und das
ist ein Risiko was ist wenn das schief
geht wollen wir nicht etwas das ein
bisschen mehr diversifiziert ist ich
denke das sind die Fragen mit der sich
die zentralbankengemeinschaft
auseinandersetzen
muss Bitcoin oder Facebooks Libra haben
viele der Zentralbanken zum Nachdenken
gebracht digitale zentralbankwährungen
auf der blockchain sogenannte cbdcs sind
ein seit 2018 intensiv diskutiertes
Thema viele Zentralbanken der Welt
diskutieren bereit ihre Einführung oder
planen Sie
konkret wir werden also bald einen
digitalen Euro
haben aber was bedeutet das überhaupt
hinter dem digitalen Euro steht nämlich
kein Konzern und auch keine
Geschäftsbank sondern die Europäische
Zentralbank und das wichtigste Ziel der
EZB ist Preisstabilität einfacher gesagt
ein Brot kostet mit dem digitalen Euro
in Zukunft noch genauso viel wie jetzt
mit der Mastercard und genau das ist
seit dem Aufkommen und der immer höheren
Akzeptanz von kryptowährungen wie
Bitcoin und Co nicht mehr so einfach
über diese Zahlungsmittel vor allem
deren unberechenbare Wertsteigerungen
bzw Verluste haben die Zentralbanken
keine Kontrolle die EZB möchte dem
entgegenwirken und stattdessen eine
stabile digitale Währung als
Weiterentwicklung des klassischen Euros
einführen das hieße dass wir neben den
jetzigen Zahlungsmöglichkeiten Bar oder
per Karte eine dritte bekommen einen
elektronischen Euro den wir über das
Smartphone aber auch über eine
Datenkarte nutzen können viele
Finanzexperten halten das für längst
überfällig denn in den meisten
skandinavischen Ländern kann kaum noch
mit Bargeld gezahlt werden und darauf
muss die EZB reagieren derzeit prüft die
EZB unter welchen Voraussetzungen dieses
digitale Zentralbankgeld sicher
eingeführt werden könnte ezbchefin
lagard betonte in einem Bloomberg
exklusiv Interview wiederholt wie
wichtig es sei die Sicherheit einer
digitalen Währung zu garantieren und das
Vertrauen in diese zu stärken
okay ich lege jetzt mal meine eigene
Überzeugung ab weil ich die Präsidentin
der Europäischen Zentralbank
bin es gibt ein Verwaltungsrat in dem
alle Präsidenten der nationalen
Zentralbanken sowie die Mitglieder des
Direktoriums vertreten sind und die
Entscheidung ob wir einen digitalen Euro
einführen werden oder nicht wird von
diesem Organ also dem Direktorium und
dem Rat der Zentralbanken
getroffen und das wird Mitte des Jahres
2021 passieren wenn wir die erst
vor dieser Bericht wird eine Analyse von
über 8000 Rückmeldungen veröffentlichen
die wir im Rahmen des Beratungsprozesses
erhalten haben er wird dem Europäischen
Parlament vorgetragen einem der
Hauptakteure sowie der Kommission und
dem EU-Rat nicht zu vergessen der
Eurogruppe danach wird der ezbrat auf
Grundlage dieser Beratung und unserer
vorangegangenen Arbeit entscheiden ob
wir mit dem Experiment digitale Euro
weitermachen daraufhin wird es eine
zweite Entscheidung geben wahrscheinlich
in einem Jahr oder lassen Sie es se
Monate sein ob aufgrund dieser ersten
Bewertung tatsächlich schon ein
digitaler Euro eingeführt
wird aber lassen Sie uns das realistisch
betrachten der ganze Prozess wird meiner
Meinung nach noch weitere vier Jahre
dauern vielleicht noch etwas länger also
ich hoffe natürlich dass wir es
innerhalb von vi Jahren schaffen aber
bringt eine Menge technischeer Aspekte
als auch grundlegende Veränderungen mit
sich und wir müssen sicherstellen dass
wenn wir einen digitalen Euro einführen
wir es vernünftig machen das sind wir
den Europäern schuldig die Europäer und
Europäerinnen sollen sicher und
unbesorgt damit umgehen können sie
sollen wissen dass sie Zentralbank
gesichertes Geld
erhalten ich würde sagen es muss das
Äquivalent einer digitalen Banknote sein
mit dem gleichen Maß an Sicherheit und
Rückendeckung durch die
Zentralbank es muss also wirklich sicher
und stabil
sein wir müssen außerdem sicherstellen
dass wir nicht unser Bankensystem
zerstören sondern es
verbessern ich sage das hier sehr
deutlich da ich weiß dass bestimmte
Finanzinstitute mit denen wir zurzeit
arbeiten sich auf uns
verlassen einige Banken schauen gerade
ziemlich besorgt auf diese Entwicklung
am Finanzmarkt aber das brauchen sie
nicht denn keine Zentralbank wird
zukünftig als Kundenmanager oder
risikobewerter für die verab V kitlen
auftreten diese Finanzinstitute werden
also weiterhin koexistieren und ihre
Geschäfte tätigen können Bargeld wird
auch weiterhin verfügbar sein ebenso wie
digitale
Währung aber man muss sich das auch
anschauen wie sich das Verhalten der
Bürger innen während der covid-19 Krise
geändert hat wie sie im Internet
einkaufen oder die Art und Weise wie sie
essen bestellen oder
bezahlen bewegt sich bereit einer
digitalen vor der wir keine Angst haben
sollten und wie ich schon sagte wir
müssen den Europäern und Europäerinnen
einen sicheren stabilen Alternativen
zahlungsmechanismus
bieten also weitere vier Jahre
Entwicklungszeit haben wir diese Zeit
noch um ein durchdachtes und technisch
ausgereiftes digitales Eurosystem
einzuführen die Ausgabe eines digitalen
Euros wäre für fast alle Tätigkeiten des
Eurosystems von Bedeutung und hätte
weitreichende Auswirkungen auf die
gesamte Gesellschaft gleichzeitig sind
aber auch Experimente zu den praktischen
Aspekten eines digitalen Euros notwendig
um die Stärken und Schwächen der
verschiedenen Optionen zu
untersuchen wir haben gehört dass viele
Banken um ihre Existenz fürchten die
Einführung eines digitalen Euros könnte
die Transmission der Geldpolitik
beeinträchtigen und sich negativ auf die
finanzstabil
auswiken auch in Krisensituationen wenn
die Sparer weniger Vertrauen in den
gesamten Bankensektor haben könnten
liquideemittel sehr schnell in den
digitalen Euro umgeschichtet werden wenn
also das Abheben von digitalem Geld
einfacher wird als das Abheben von
Bargeld könnte es die Wahrscheinlichkeit
von schweren bankruns erhöhen und die
Finanzstabilität
[Musik]
Schwächen diese Beispiele machen
deutlich dass die Ausgestaltung des
digitalen Euros sorgfältig geprüft
werden muss es sollte vor allem über
überlegt werden ob er für Haushalte und
Unternehmen direkt oder indirekt über
Banken zugänglich sein sollte ob er
vergütet und ob die digitalen eurob
Bestände einzelner NutzerInnen begrenzt
oder unbegrenzt sein
sollten für den Moment halten wir uns
die Option offen ob und wann dies
geschehen
soll Aufgabe der EZB ist es das
Vertrauen in das Geld zu sichern es muss
sichergestellt werden dass der Euro fit
für das digitale Zeitalter ist die
Kommission der EZB hat einiges en
beschrieben die das Eurosystem zur
Ausgabe eines digitalen Euros
veranlassen könnte und auch
Anforderungen aufgeführt die die neue
Geldform erfüllen
sollte Szenario 1 positive Auswirkungen
auf Innovation und Autonomie der
Eurozone Unabhängigkeit und
Digitalisierung der europäischen
Wirtschaft können von einer digitalen
Form des zentralbankgeldes profitieren
die den Bürgern zur Verfügung gestellt
wird die Ausgabe eines digitalen Euros
kann ein Weg sein die digitalisier der
Wirtschaft zu fördern und die
Entwicklung innovativer europäischer
Lösungen in allen möglichen Branchen zu
unterstützen in einem solchen Szenario
würde die Ausgabe eines digitalen Euros
dazu beitragen die europäische Autonomie
im Bereich des massenzahlungsverkehrs zu
erhalten und könnte ein Baustein für
eine europäische Lösung für Point of
Sale und online Zahlungen sein Szenario
2 die Rolle von Bargeld als
Zahlungsmittel nimmt deutlich ab die
europäischen Bürgerinnen hätten somit
Schwierigkeiten auf das einzige
Zahlungsmittel zuzugreifen das vom
öffentlichen Sektor bereitgestellt wird
extreme Ereignisse wie covid-19 können
die Veränderung der Zahlungsgewohnheiten
beschleunigen durch steigende
Wartungskosten der bargeldinfrastruktur
könnte der Rückgang der Verfügbarkeit
und Akzeptanz von Bargeld zusätzlich
vorangetrieben werden ein ähnlicher
Trend wird sich wahrscheinlich aus der
rasanten Entwicklung des elektronischen
Handels
ergeben Szenario 3 eine andere Geldform
als eurodominiertes Zentralbankgeld oder
elektronisches Geld wird zu einer
glaubwürdigen Alternative zu
wertaufbewahrungsmitteln in der Eurozone
private Akteure wie Bitcoin oder Libra
welche außerhalb der Aufsicht der
europäischen Finanzbehörden stehen oder
auch bigtech Unternehmen die nicht Euro
dominiert sind welche eine globale
Verbreitung erreichen und für große
Zahlungen im Euroraum genutzt werden
könnten die Geldpolitik im Euroraum
Schwächen ihr Einfluss hätte auch
unklare Auswirkungen auf die
grenzüberschreitende Kapitalmobilität
was letztlich die Finanzstabilität
beeinträchtigen könnte unter diesen
Umständen könnte die Ausgabe eines
digitalen Euro muss die europäische
Souveränität und Stabilität
[Musik]
unterstützen Szenario 4 die EU
beschließt Verbesserungen der
Gesamtkosten und des ökologischen
Fußabdrucks seiner Geld und
Zahlungssysteme proaktiv zu unterstützen
die Herstellung von zahlungsinstrumenten
und deren Infrastrukturen ist nicht
immer energieeffizient ein gut
konzipierter digitaler Euro kann daher
dazu beitragen die Gesamtkosten und den
ökologischen Fußabdruck der
Zahlungssysteme im Euro Raum zu
verringern in diesem Zusammenhang würde
das Eurosystem eine katalysatorrolle
spielen und mit gutem Beispiel
vorangehen indem es Anreize schafft und
Druck auf die Anbieter von
Zahlungsdienstleistungen
ausübt aus diesen vier Szenarien lassen
sich folgende Anforderungen ableiten der
digitale Euro sollte so gestaltet sein
dass etweige negative Auswirkungen auf
die Geldpolitik und Finanzstabilität
abgeschwächt werden die übermäßige
Nutzung des digitalen Euros als
Anlageform und des damit verbundenen
Risikos großer Umschichtungen sollten
vermieden werden der digitale Euro
sollte im Vergleich zu alternativen ein
effizienter Weg sein die ökonomischen
und ökologischen Ziele der Eurozone zu
[Musik]
erreichen aber bei all den Visionen und
Ideen sehen wir nicht in der technischen
Umsetzung die größte
Herausforderung wie kann für den
Endverbraucher den Lieferanten oder den
Unternehmer sichergestellt werden dass
ein digitaler Euro jeder Zeit verfügbar
ist und überall akzeptiert wird und
welche Rolle spielt dabei der Faktor
Zeit China testet bereits seine
staatliche digitalwährung namens euan es
kommen bereits Apps zum Einsatz mit
denen Zahlungen in euan realisiert
werden können sogar staatliche
Leistungen werden zum Teil in der neuen
digitalwährung
ausgezahlt mit dem digitalen han
reagiert China auf kryptowährungen wie
Bitcoin dabei setzt Chinas
digitalwährung nur teilweise auf eine
blockchain es kommen auch traditionelle
verrechnungsmethoden zum Einsatz auch
Facebooks Libra oder jetzt DM sollte
NutzerInnen auf Plattformen wie WhatsApp
oder Instagram die Möglichkeit geben die
digitale Währung beim Online Shopping zu
nutzen Facebook stieß allerdings
weltweit in der Politik und bei den
Notenbanken auf Widerstand viele sahen
in dem Projekt einen Angriff des
Privatunternehmens auf das staatliche
währungsmonopol und kündigten eine
starke Regulierung von privaten
digitalwährungen an Brian Brooks der CEO
von bin befürchtet dass wir ohne
Regulierungen unserer Geldpolitik keine
digitalen Währungen erfolgreich
realisieren
können nun nach meiner persönlichen
Ansicht ist hier in erster Linie der
Nutzen zu betrachten darüber sollten wir
sprechen bitte bedenken Sie dass jede
kryptowährung eine andere Funktion
repräsentiert das sind alles
verschiedene Netzwerke die für
unterschiedliche Dinge entworfen werden
wenn wir also über Bitcoin sprechen ist
der im Grunde ein Investment asset also
eine Art digitales Gold und wenn Bitcoin
reguliert werden sollte sollte es ebenso
wie Investitionsgüter werden es ist
natürlich kein Wertpapier aber es ist
etwas das die Leute wegen seiner
werterhaltungseigenschaften kaufen und
halten im Gegensatz zu ethereum das ist
ein Netzwerk für Zahlungsverkehr oder
für Crowdsourcing von Finanzierungen
wenn es sich also um einen
zahlungsmechanismus handelt würden sie
erwarten dass die Banken
Aufsichtsbehörden darüber sprechen das
war meine Tätigkeit bei der OCC es
sollte also genau nach Nutzungsklassen
reguliert werden die jetzt auch nach
asset Kategorien reguliert wird und wenn
es sich um einen zahlungsmechanismus
handelt sollte er wie ein
zahlungsmechanismus reguliert werden ich
denke das ist hier der richtige
Denkansatz facebook hat sein Konzept
einer digitalen Währung stark
abgewandelt um die Volatilität seines
Kurses gering zu halten soll es zunächst
nur einen sogenannten stablecoin geben
der jeweils einen US-Dollar abbildet und
dessen Preis dynamisch bzw automatisch
gesteuert werden kann auch den Namen hat
Facebook geändert der Libra heißt nun
dimdllar ein Zulassungsantrag für die
Europäische Union ist allerdings noch
nicht
eingegangen warum also die EU som mit
der Einführung einer digitalen Währung
Christine lagard meint es geht nur im
Zusammenspiel von Markt und
[Musik]
Regulatoren wir müssen uns mit Fragen
des Datenschutzes befassen und mit
vielen Fragen die in gewisser Weise über
den Bereich der Zentralbanken
hinausgehen das heißt wir sind gezwungen
mit anderen Behörden zusammenzuarbeiten
z.B den Finanzministerien und den
Parlamenten der Europäischen Kommission
denn wenn der Zeitpunkt kommt wird es
das Leben vieler Menschen auf eine sehr
intime Weise ändern wir hören den
Europäerinnen zu und wissen was Ihnen
wichtig ist sie wollen dass Ihre
Privatsphäre geschützt ist aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir auch
sicherstellen dass es nicht zu einer
Ausweitung von Geldwäsche oder
terrorfinanzierung führt wir müssen also
bei jedem einzelnen Aspekt die richtige
Balance finden das wird noch ein paar
Jahre dauern und wenn diese Arbeit
abgeschlossen ist wird der Regierungsrat
entscheiden ob er uns hierfür grünes
Licht gibt oder wir die ganze Sache
stoppen dass wir für die nächsten zwei
Jahre viel Unterstützung vom ezbrat
erwarten können und hoffentlich das
volle Budget bereitgestellt wird denn
das ganze funktioniert nicht ohne Kosten
zu verursachen aber in zwei Jahren wird
sich dann entscheiden ob es ein Let's Go
ist und wir einen digitalen Euro
bekommen oder nicht nun mit Blick auf
die Märkte haben wir rational versucht
sie zu verstehen oder ihre Gedanken zu
verstehen und was ihre Erwartungen sind
klar ich als Person spreche selbst nicht
mit den Märkten und ich denke das ist
auch nicht mein Aufgabengebiet es ist
sogar meine Pflicht mich daraus zu
halten aber wir haben natürlich Leute
die den Markt beobachten und ihn
kennen ich meine man kann kein großer
Einkäufer sein ohne tatsächlich eine
gewisse Nähe dazu zu haben wie Märkte
funktionieren und wie sie ticken vor
allem die Erwartungen sind von
entscheidender
Bedeutung wir führen also marktumfragen
durch an denen die Unternehmen
teilnehmen und die wir genau
Auswerten das ist aber nicht die einzige
Komponente wir schauen auf alle
möglichen Indikatoren und
Umfragen wir sind fest entschlossen und
vollständig auf unser Ziel fixiert die
Preisstabilität zu erhalten die wir den
Europäern und Europäerinnen liefern
müssen das ist für uns das Wichtigste
aber die Märkte spielen natürlich auch
eine Rolle und wir müssen auf sie achten
und überlegen wie sie die Dinge sehen
aber unser Ziel ist natürlich
Preisstabilität die Finanz der größten
Eurostaaten unter anderem Deutschland
Frankreich Spanien und Italien haben
sich gegen einen digitalen Schnellschuss
ausgesprochen eine digitale Währung
dürfte nicht eingeführt werden bevor
nicht alle damit verbundenen Risiken
auch in der Gesetzgebung angemessen
berücksichtigt worden sind darüber
hinaus wirgt die Einschränkung der
Verwendung eines digitalen Euros die
Gefahr dass die Konvertierbarkeit zu
anderen Formen des Euros beeinträchtigt
wird Zinsänderungen oder Märkte auf
denen der digitale Euro wie eine
Parallelwährung behandelt wird stellen
eine Bedrohung für die Verwendung des
Euros als Zahlungsmittel in der
Wirtschaft da dass die Einführung einer
digitalen Währung durchaus positive
Effekte auf die Stabilität eines Landes
haben kann zeigt sich am Beispiel
Venezuela das Startup value hilft den
Menschen in Venezuela im Kampf gegen die
Hyperinflation ich heiße Simon chamero
ich bin Mitbegründer und CEO von value
unser Produkt hilft den Venezolanern mit
der Hyperinflation umzugehen und ihr
Geld vor Wertverlust zu schützen
Überweisungen zu erhalten vor Ort zu
bezahlen und um Lebensmittel und
Medikamente zu
kaufen sowohl Unternehmen als auch
Verbraucher sind in der Lage waren und
Dienstleistungen miteinander zu tauschen
und in kryptowährung zu bezahlen unsere
Vision ist es die wirtschaftliche
Freiheit zu
erhöhen venezuela ist bekannt für seine
politische und wirtschaftliche
Instabilität die Hyperinflation hat dazu
geführt dass der boliva in nur 2 Jahren
99% seines wert verlor wohlhabende
Familien sahen ihr Vermögen schwinden
und einkommensschwache Menschen wurden
noch weiter in die Verzweiflung
getrieben Simon chamoro kennt diese
Geschichte nur allzu
gut als ich in Venezuela aufwuchs ging
im Grunde alles was mein Vater und meine
Mutter in ihrem Leben aufbauen konnten
verloren als die Wirtschaft
zusammenbrach wir hatten z. be
Wasserknappheit oder Stromausfälle im
ganzen Land das Geld fing an
hyperinflationär zu werden
das ist keine traurige Geschichte die
ich hier versuche zu erzählen das ist
leider die Realität der meisten
Venezolaner mehr als 99% der Venezolaner
haben alles verloren was sie aufgebaut
haben weil das Land gescheitert ist alle
Ersparnisse aus der Mittelschicht die
sich etwas aufbauen wollte lösten sich
in Luft auf ich wollte meine Bestimmung
finden und wusste immer dass ich ein
Unternehmen gründen und Dinge entwickeln
wollte weshalb ich dann auch
Industriedesign studierte ich glaubte
fest daran in der Lage zu sein Dinge zu
verändern letztendlich habe ich diese
Karriere nicht weiter verfolgt aber ich
habe eine Menge Dinge gelernt die mir
die Technologie näher gebracht haben und
so bin ich beim Thema Krypto gelandet
ich habe mich dafür begeistert und als
ich dann das Potenzial von Krypto
Verstand wurde mir klar dass Venezuela
der perfekte Ort ist um solche Ideen in
großem Maßstab
umzusetzen tatsächlich könnte eine
dekonstruierung der kryptowährung der
Mittelschicht helfen und dies hat die
Möglichkeit unsere Gesellschaft wie wir
sie kennen grundlegend zu
verändern das Hauptproblem der
Venezolaner ist im Moment die
Hyperinflation und diese ist nur das
Nebenprodukt einer totalen
Misswirtschaft dieses
Landes Venezuelas Abstieg in eine
verarmte Diktatur hat der Welt die
verhirrenden Auswirkungen der
Hyperinflation vor Augen geführt
schleppende Grundversorgung extreme
Knappheit an Lebensmitteln und
medizinischen Mitteln
Bürgerkriege Gewalt Venezulaner die ihre
Währung aus Venezuela in andere
stabilere Währungen wie den US-Dollar
transferieren konnten blieben verschont
ein Luxus der meist nur für die
ultraelite in Frage kam mittels
kryptowährung möchte Simon mit seiner
Plattform value allen die Möglichkeit
geben sich gegen die Hyperinflation zu
wehren seiner Meinung nach sind die
instabilen Verhältnisse in seinem Land
der perfekte nähboden für ein solches
Experiment ni traut mehr der Währung
oder der Regierung die Menschen suchen
nach
Lösungen an einem Ort an dem die
Menschen versuchen zu überleben ist die
Hemmschwelle viel niedriger neue Dinge
auszuprobieren sei es dieseld doollars
tischmünzen kryptowährungen die Leute
werden bereit sein mit wenig Geld zu
starten und dann langsam versuchen es
irgendwie zu etablieren unser
hauptzielemoment als Unternehmen ist es
Händlern zu ermöglichen den dito Dollar
als Zahlungsmittel zu akzeptieren sodass
die Leute immer weniger gezwungen sind
den bouivard zu benutzen
wir konzentrieren uns darauf ein Produkt
zu entwickeln das von den Reichen
gebildeten und technisch versierten bis
hin zu den Menschen mit den niedrigen
Einkommen und geringen technischen
Kenntnissen genutzt werden kann in einem
Land wie Venezuela wo der Mindestlohn
bei ungefähr einem Dollar liegt haben
sie die Situation dass die meisten Leute
ihr eigenes kleines Geschäft eröffnen
Hotdogs verkaufen oder lokales Essen wie
arepas oder was auch immer aber sie
verkaufen es vorwiegend in ihren
superriesigen Gemeinden also wollen wir
den Gemeinden helfen Zahlungen in Dollar
bzw in dito Dollar also stable Coins zu
akzeptieren und Nutzer zu erreichen je
mehr Verbraucher in Dollar zahlen desto
besser für die Händler je mehr Händler
es akzeptieren umso besser für die
Verbraucher bis heute haben wir
Millionen von Dollar bewegt und haben
damit mehr als 150 000 Haushalten
geholfen 30.000 aktive Nutzer monatlich
und wir sehen dass es funktioniert in
Wirklichkeit kann wirtschaftliche
Freiheit nur direkt durch Innovation
erreicht werden was kryptowährungen
sind dabei darf man nicht vergessen dass
Venezuela dies bereits versucht hat el
Petro war der Versuch eine kryptowährung
zu etablieren die durch die
reichhaltigste Ressource des Landes
unterstützt wurde Öl während el Petro
weithin als durchschlagender Misserfolg
betrachtet wurde sind sich viele
Experten einig dass dieses Experiment
ein notwendiger Schritt war um eine
digitale Währung für die Zukunft zu
etablieren und Simon ist überzeugt dass
deren Grundlage nämlich die blockchain
technie n stärker den je benötigt wird
und sein Land bereit ist für einen
weiteren
Versuch die blockchain Technologie ist
tatsächlich eine Art Paradigmenwechsel
für die Menschheit eines der
bedeutsamsten Dinge unserer
Zeit man sieht langsam dass immer mehr
Unternehmen damit beginnen ihre Produkte
komplett auf einer blockchain
aufzubauen es ist fast so als würde sich
eine eigene Wirtschaft
entwickeln wenn es einen Weg ohne Krypto
gäbe den Venezolanern ihre Stabilität
und wirtschaftliche sowie finanzielle
Freiheit zurückzugeben wäre das
natürlich ein viel besserer Weg als mit
einem Produkt Erfolg zu haben das in
sich gar keinen Wert
besitzt die Hyperinflation Venezuelas
zeigt dass die Geldpolitik eines Landes
nicht immer nach den internationalen
Spielregeln
funktioniert unsere Erwartung die
Geldpolitik einer Zentralbank kann uns
jederzeit retten sollte unser Geld in
Schieflage geraten muss also in Zukunft
hinterfragt werden wenn sogar ein
erdölreiches Land wie Venezuela in eine
Hyperinflation geraten kann einer der
diese quantitativen Lockerungen in der
Geldpolitik schon länger in Frage stellt
ist Ravi
[Musik]
mennon ich denke das ist falsch und ich
denke auch es ist falsch wenn
Zentralbanken diese Erwartung zu
quantitativen Lockerungen
nähren die Geldpolitik bildet die
Grundlage für ein nachhaltiges nichtl
Wirtschaftswachstum sie sorgt für
Stabilität und zumindest auf mittlere
Sicht für
Vorhersagbarkeit und auf dieser Basis
kann man dann
Wirtschaften aber es kann nicht sein
dass jede Abschwächung jedes Risiko oder
jede wirtschaftliche Bedrohung die am
Horizont auftaucht eine Lockerung der
Geldpolitik nach sich zieht ich denke
dass Fiskalpolitik eine enorm wichtige
Rolle spielt und wir das nicht
ausreichend berücksichtigen auch zum
Teil weil der Geldpolitik zu viel
Gewicht beigemessen wird wir brauchen
hier ein besser Gleichgewicht zwischen
beiden alles andere wäre auch unfair
gegenüber der zentralbankengemeinschaft
und da sie gerade quantitative
Lockerungen ansprechen Singapur braucht
diese Lockerung nicht weil unsere
Geldpolitik an unseren Wechselkurs
gekoppelt ist wir unterliegen also nicht
der Nullzinspolitik selbst wenn man über
Negativzinsen und quantitative
Lockerungen als Ergänzung zu einer
wechselkurszentrierten Geldpolitik
nachdenkt diese Überlegungen Treffen für
uns nicht zu wir können wenn nötig den
wechselkurspfad wieder auf Null absenken
bitte verstehen Sie mich nicht falsch
wir haben noch nie absichtlich eine
Politik der Währungsabwertung betrieben
aber wir können den Wechselkurs
jederzeit wieder nach unten korrigieren
was wir in der Vergangenheit auch schon
getan haben wenn wir der Meinung sind
dass der aktuelle Wechselkurs zu eng ist
können wir ihn jederzeit nach unten
rezentrieren und mit dieser Flexibilität
gibt es eigentlich keine Einschränkung
wir haben also einen ziemlich großen
geldpolitischen Spielraum ohne dass wir
über quantitative Lockerungen nachdenken
müssen
während die EZB also derzeit noch an
einem Konzept zum digitalen Euro
arbeitet sind Zentralbanken anderer
Staaten meist schon einen Schritt weiter
2018 gab auch das oberste bankeninstitut
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
Deutsche Bundesbank bekannt aktiv an
einer blockchain basierten Lösung zu
arbeiten das Institut mit Hauptsitz in
Frankfurt am Main verwaltet rund 200
Milliarden Euro an staatlichen Reserven
und ist Teil des europäischen Systems
der Zentralbanken nach eigenen Angaben
intensiviert die Bank nun seine
Forschung im Bereich der distributed
Ledger technology und hat bereits einen
entsprechenden Partner genannt Ocean
protocol soll zukünftig mit seiner
Technologie die Deutsche Bundesbank in
ihrem Vorhaben unterstützen das 2017 in
Singapur gegründete Unternehmen
entwickelt innovative Apps für die
kommende datenökonomie und verbindet
Datenanbieter und Nutzer mit Hilfe der
blockchain Technologie Ocean ermöglicht
es dateneigentümern Daten zu
monitarisieren und gleichzeitig die
Kontrolle über Ihre Datenbestände zu
behalten die Deutsche Bundesbank ruft
also ein eigenes blockchain Projekt ins
Leben der Fokus dieser Zusammenarbeit
liegt hierbei auf einem dezentralen
Netzwerk das Nutzern einen permanent
symmetrischen Zugriff auf Daten
gestattet dadurch sollen beispielsweise
echtzeitaktualisierungen von Statistiken
unter Wahrung der Datenhoheit möglich
sein von der Bundesbank hieß es Ocean
protocol war als einziges Unternehmen in
der Lage eine technische Lösung für
unser Vorhaben anzubieten die bereits
funktionsfähig
ist außerdem soll eine Plattform für die
sichere Verwahrung Übertragung und
Nutzung öffentlicher und privater Daten
entwickelt werden offen bleibt ob das
Unternehmen aus Singapur auch bei der
Forschung an einem digitalen Euro
beteiligt
ist doch wie sieht es mit den deutschen
Unternehmen aus wie denken diese im
allgemeinen über die Einführung und
Nutzbarkeit eines digitalen
Euros 7 pro also dreiviertel aller
Unternehmen ab 50 Beschäftigten sind für
die Einführung eines digitalen Euros nur
jedes fünte Unternehmen 20% hält diese
Pläne für wenig erfolgversprechend das
ist das Ergebnis einer jüngsten Umfrage
unter 652 Unternehmen aller Branchen in
Deutschland aus dem Jahr
2021 vor allem die Möglichkeit dass
sonst andere private digitalwährungen
zum Einsatz kommen die europäische Werte
untergraben könnten spricht aus sich der
Unternehmen für einen alen Euro 69% der
Unternehmen sehen es als notwendig an
mit tokenisierten Wertpapieren nahtlose
zahlungsund Abwicklungsprozesse auf dem
Kapitalmarkt zu
ermöglichen fast genauso viele nämlich
64% denken dass es von Vorteil ist einen
digitalen Euro zu haben sollte die
Bedeutung von Bargeld abnehmen so hätten
Bürger im digitalen Zeitalter weiterhin
direkten Zugang zur Zentralbank das ein
digitaler Euro ist der EZB in
Krisenzeiten ermöglicht innovative
geldpolitische Instrumente effektiver
umzusetzen Glauben 60% der
Befragten rund 40% würden gern
Zahlungsprozesse zunehmend
automatisieren und sehen hier den Bedarf
für einen programmierbaren Euro in der
Industrie Stichwort M2M payment also
machine to machine Zahlungen im Internet
nur 11% sind der Meinung ein digitaler
Euro hätte überhaupt keine
Vorteile neben den Verfechtern des
digitalen Zeitalters gibt es allerdings
auch Skeptiker rund um die Einführung
eines digitalen Euros 65% also etwa zwei
Drittel sehen hier datenschutzrisiken
sollte die Zentralbank tiefere Einblicke
in unsere Zahlungsprozesse erhalten auch
sieht ungefähr jedes zweite Unternehmen
dadurch die Finanzstabilität gefährdet
denn durch die Ausgabe des digitalen
Euros könnte der Einfluss der Banken in
Krisenzeiten sinken doch nur 3% der
Banken und Finanzdienstleister halten
nichts von der Ausgabe eines digitalen
Euros durch die
EZB ca 8% der Gesamtwirtschaft meint die
Wirtschaft müsste eigene Lösungen für
den digitalen Zahlungsverkehr der
Zukunft entwickeln 13% geben an es
spreche nichts gegen einen digitalen
Euro so sprechen sich 35% des Banken und
Finanzgeschäfts für die Einführung eines
digitalen Euros
aus in der Bewertung zur Tendenz würden
46% eher einem digitalen Euro zustimmen
und nur 9% sagen klar
nein
die EZB ist jedenfalls fest entschlossen
einen digitalen Euro einzuführen den
sogenannten
eeuro dieser soll parallel zum Bargeld
ausgegeben werden das ausdrücklich nicht
abgeschafft werden soll damit reagiert
die EZB auf zahlreiche neue Formen des
Bezahlens wie z.B cryptoassets wie etwa
Bitcoin dim oder Chinas
euan EZB Präsidentin lagard geht davon
aus dass der Euro schon in vier Jahren
in den virtuellen Geldbörsen der
VerbraucherInnen der Eurozone liegen
wird und dann auch kräftig zum Einsatz
kommt China ist bei der Entwicklung
einer digitalen Währung weit voraus und
auch Schwedens Zentralbank arbeitet an
der digitalen Krone wie der eeuro am
Ende genau aussieht wissen auch die
Währungshüter noch nicht aber so viel
ist bereits klar der digitale Euro wird
wie Bargeld von der EZB ausgegeben und
kontrolliert es entsteht also wie Münzen
Scheine oder Buch Geld das auf dem
Girokonto oder Sparbuch liegt durch die
Geldschöpfung der EZB und der
Geschäftsbanken im Unterschied zum
Bitcoin und anderen cryptoassets behält
also die Notenbank die Kontrolle über
die Währung womit Stabilität und
Sicherheit des digitalen Euros
garantiert werden soll der Euro soll in
einer Art virtuellen Geldbörse
aufbewahrt werden und mittels eines
einfachen Verfahrens z.B durch eine App
oder einen QR-Code in die virtuelle
Kasse des Verkäufers wandern dies wird
online z.B spel wieer Internet als auch
offline über Bluetooth möglich sein eine
Zahlung soll in Zukunft also viel
einfacher und auch viel schneller
möglich sein als bisher über SEPA
Überweisung funktionieren soll das ganze
über ein separates Konto sozusagen einem
direktkonto bei der EZB dennoch
verwaltet durch die Geschäftsbanken so
ist der eeuro selbst dann nur noch durch
die EZB geschützt wenn private
Finanzinstitute durch eine Krise in
Schieflage geraten auch der Schutz der
Privatsphäre ist zunehmend gesichert da
im Unterschied zu großen amerikanischen
Kreditkartenunternehmen bei der
Transaktion keine persönlichen Daten
übermittelt werden am 14 Juli hat der
Rat der Europäischen Zentralbank
beschlossen das Projekt digitaler Euro
einzuläuten es wurden eine Menge
Analysen vorgenommen Feedback von
BürgerInnen sowie aus Fachkreisen
eingeholt und eine praktische Erprobung
durchgeführt mit vermutigenden
Ergebnissen all dies hat den statschuss
für das Projekt digital Euro ermöglicht
und wer weiß vielleicht werden wir in
vier Jahren mit dem digitalen Euro
genauso selbstverständlich einkaufen wie
bisher mit Kredit oder Debitkarte die
EZB und der Euroraum sind auf einem
guten Weg unser Finanzsystem
kontrolliert und sicher in das digitale
Zeitalter zu führen der digitale Euro
wird ein nächster großer Schritt in die
Zukunft für Europa und seine BürgerInnen
sein
[Musik]